autour de la table plus de 40 pays
soutient de l'ukraine et de facto allié
de washington objectif déterminer les
besoins nécessaires à l'effort militaire
de kiev en pleine contre offensive pour
tenter de récupérer des territoires sous
contrôle de l'armée russe désormais
figée le conflit s'est mué en guerre de
positions qui nécessite une quantité
très importante de munitions
nous sommes ici parce que nous refusons
de vivre dans un monde où de grandes
puissances piétine des frontières par la
force
notre soutien aux droits de l'ukraine à
se défendre ne faiblira pas face à
l'adversité
la semaine dernière le cren a lancé
plusieurs opérations militaires pour
récupérer ses territoires perdus
kiev affirme avoir fait une avancée
significative dans la région de rares
kiffe mais l'objectif principal reste le
contrôle de la ville stratégique de
personnes au sud du pays pour y parvenir
l'armée ukrainienne qui a épuisé tout
son stock d'armement ne peut rien faire
sans âge occidental en visite à kiev le
secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken viennent annoncer une nouvelle
aide militaire globale de près de 3
milliards de dollars pour kiev et pour
ses voisins dont 700 millions dette
directe en armement pour l'ukraine hier
les médias américains faisaient état de
stocks quasi vide de munitions pour
l'armée russe d'après ses informations
moscou aurait reconstitué une partie de
son artillerie en faisant appel à la
corée du nord et à l'iran notamment